WELL, THAT DIDN'T LAST LONG.
ON JANUARY 1, MITT ROMNEY, A MAN
SO STIFF YOU COULD IRON A SHIRT
ON HIM, THAT IS THE PRESIDENT
AND "THE WASHINGTON POST."
REMEMBER THAT?
YOU KNOW THE DRILL.
TRUMP IS RUDE.
HE LACKS CHARACTER AND SO ON.
COULD HAVE BEEN WRITTEN ON
JANUARY 1, 2018 OR 2017 OR 1517.
IF THE DEFINITION OF INSANITY IS
COMPLAINING ABOUT SOMETHING THAT
WILL NEVER CHANGE, MITT HAS MADE
IT TO THE LOONIE BIN AND HE WAS
HELPED BY MEDIA ACTING LIKE THE
BLAST FROM THE PAST TO INDULGE
HIS UNHAPPY EXES.
MITT IS STILL MAD ABOUT TRUMP.
"WASHINGTON POST" AND CNN WILL
LET HIM CRY ON THE SHOULDER.
IT'S TEMPTING FOR MITT.
IT FEELS GOOD TO GET HUGS FROM A
MEDIA WHO ONCE FRIENDED YOU A
SEXIST BULLY AND HURTS DOGS AND
KEEPS WOMEN IN BINDERS.
OBAMA'S DRY LAUGH WHEN MITT
MAYBE RUSH IS A PROBLEM.
THIS ATTENTION IS A STRANGE NEW
RESPECT THAT'S GONE BY TOMORROW.
THE MEDIA MAY PRETEND TO LIKE
YOU BECAUSE YOU HATE TRUMP BUT
THEY ARE JUST USING YOU.
THE MEDIA WAS BRUTAL TO MITT AS
THEY ARE TO ANYONE RIGHT OF
GASTRITIS TRUMP HADN'T WON, HAD
A BEN RUBIO OR BUSH, DO YOU
THINK THEY WOULD'VE BEEN SPARED?
JEB WOULD HAVE BEEN CALLED A
WARMONGER AND RUBIO A
MISOGYNIST.
TO THE PRESS, AND ONLY
ACCEPTABLE REPUBLICAN IS AN
EX-REPUBLICAN.
HER NAME IS JOE SCARBOROUGH.
MITT, THAT WARM GLOW YOU FEEL
FROM THE LEFT ISN'T TRUE LOVE.
IT'S A BUG ZAPPER.
THEY WILL PULL YOU OUT AS LONG
AS YOU DISS TRUMP BUT ONLY UNTIL
IT'S TIME FOR THEM TO FRY YOUR
ASS.
JESSE, WELCOME BACK.
WHY IS HE DOING THIS?
I THOUGHT IT WAS BECAUSE HE WAS
GOING TO CHALLENGE TRUMP BUT
THEN I HEARD HE SAID HE HAS NO
INTEREST IN THAT.
>> HE MIGHT FLIP-FLOP ON THAT.
HE HAS FLIP-FLOPPED ON THE PAST.
WE GET IT, MITT.
YOU HAVE GREAT CHARACTER.
YOU DRINK MILK.
YOU DON'T CURSE.
IT'S CLEAR YOU ARE A MORMON.
YOU GO TO CHURCH EVERY SUNDAY.
YOU'RE PERFECT.
WE GET IT.
NOW YOU'RE BECOMING A SCOLD AND
IT'S TURNING PEOPLE OFF.
THE GUY, AND I VOTED FOR HIM
INTO PRIMARIES IN 2008 AND 2012
ON THE REPUBLICAN PRIMARY BUT HE
SAYS AWKWARD POLITICAL INSTINCTS
AND HE DOES THINGS AND
SELF-SERVING WAYS.
CHANGED HIS POSITION ON
ABORTION, THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE, IMMIGRATION, IN THE
1980s HE SAID HE WASN'T A
REAGAN REPUBLICAN.
I THINK AT ONE POINT HE WAS PRO
TRUMP AND THEN HE WAS ANTI-TRUMP
AND KEEP      THINGS KEEP CHANGN
AND KEEP      THINGS KEEP CHANG.
LOOK WHAT HAPPENED WHEN HE RAN
AGAINST BARACK OBAMA.
HE LET THIS GUY SMEAR HIS
BUSINESS ACUMEN, COMING FROM
BARACK OBAMA WHO WAS AN ECONOMIC
ILLITERATE.
LET IT GET AWAY AND THEY DIDN'T
GO FOR THE JUGULAR IN THE DEBATE
OVER BENGHAZI WHEN HE HAD HIM ON
THE ROPES AND LET THAT SLIDE.
HIS TIMING IS TERRIBLE.
IT'S LIKE HE DUSTED OFF A
NEVER-TRUMP OP-ED FROM THE
SUMMER OF 2016 AND SENT IT OFF
TO THE NEWSPAPER.
THIS GUY'S NOT TRYING TO PRIMARY
DONALD TRUMP.
YOU ARE JOINING A CLUB.
THE SENATE AS A CLUB.
YOU ARE TRYING TO GET ALONG AND
HE'S MAKING ABOUT HIMSELF AND I
KNOW MITCH MCCONNELL SITTING
THERE ROLLING HIS EYES WATCHING
ROMNEY COME IN AND HOTDOG ON THE
FIRST DAY.
MEANWHILE, THESE GUYS JUST
CONFIRM MARK KAVANAUGHS, KEEP
THE GOVERNMENT OPEN, AND BUILD A
WALL.
THAT'S ALL THAT VOTERS REALLY
CARE ABOUT.
>> Greg: DAN AND MARIE, I WANT
TO FIRST PLAY DONALD TRUMP'S
RESPONSE TO MITT ROMNEY.
>> I WHICH MITT -- I WISH TO BE
COULD BE MORE OF A TEAM PLAYER.
WE HAVE DONE A LOT.
I READ HIS OP-ED.
IF HE FOUGHT REALLY HARD AGAINST
PRESIDENT OBAMA LIKE HE DOES
AGAINST ME, HE WOULD'VE WON THE
ELECTION.
>> Greg: DAN, I'M SURE YOU
HAVE VERY SOFT OPINIONS ABOUT
THIS TOPIC.
>> Dan: I AM PRETTY PISSED
ABOUT THIS.
I WAS ON TWITTER ON THE PLANE
FILLETING THIS FRAUD.
HE GOES OUT AND VICIOUSLY
ATTACKED DONALD TRUMP IN THE
INITIAL SPEECH, AFTER SEEKING
HIS SUPPORT WHEN HE WAS RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT.
HE FILLETS HIM IN THIS
DISCONTINUING SPEECH AND THEN
GOES TO BEDMINSTER AND GOES TO
AN INTERVIEW FOR A CABINET
POSITION AND THEN HAS THE FAMOUS
DINNER IN NEW YORK.
ALL NEW YORK.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, THIS GUY HE HAD
CHARACTER WITH WHEN A CHILD WAS
SITTING IN FRONT OF HIM, THIS --
HE IS A TOTAL HOAX, THE BIGGEST
FRAUD AND POLITICS.
I'M SORRY.
HE IS.
HE DESERVED TO BE CALLED OUT FOR
THE FRAUD HE IS.
YOU WANTED A JOB ONCE YOU COULD
CATCH A PAYCHECK AND SOME POWER
BACK?
WHO HAS MORE CHARACTER?
AFTER TRUMP GOT FILLETED BY THIS
IDIOT IN THIS SPEECH.
I'M SORRY.
I'M REALLY PISSED ABOUT THIS.
>> Greg: I CAN TELL.
>> Dan: EVERYTHING WRONG WITH
THE SWAMP RODENTS THAT ONLY CARE
ABOUT THEMSELVES.
THIS GUYS A CLOWN.
NO ONE SHOULD TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
TRUMP GAVE HIM A SECOND AND
THIRD CHANGE AND HE STILL
SCREWED HIM OVER IN THE END.
>> Greg: MARIE, I KNOW THAT
YOU AGREE WITH EVERYTHING DAN
SAID SO WE CAN SKIP IT WILL GO
TO KENNEDY.
>> Marie: DONALD TRUMP NEEDS
TO CARE WHAT MITT ROMNEY THINKS.
HE ACTUALLY WILL NEED EVERY
REPUBLICAN VOTE.
I THINK MITT ROMNEY, WHO I -- I
WORKED ON THE 2012 CAMPAIGN.
ALL OF MY FRIENDS FOR THAT
CAMPAIGNER LIKE GOD, NOW WE HAVE
TO TALK ABOUT MITT ROMNEY AGAIN.
WE THAT DEALT WITH THAT.
I THINK HE GENUINELY BELIEVES
THIS.
HE'S A PERSON WHO SEEMS TO BE
FROM AFAR A GOOD PERSON, FAMILY
MAN, SOMEONE WHO HAS MORALS AND
CARES ABOUT THEM IN PUBLIC LIFE.
>> Greg: YOU DIDN'T SAY THAT
WHEN YOU ARE RUNNING AGAINST HI
HIM.
>> Marie: YOU WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO FIND A QUOTE FOR ME THAT
TALKS ABOUT HIS CHARACTER.
I THINK HE GENUINELY BELIEVES
THIS.
THE BIGGER POINT, DAN, ISN'T
WHETHER OR NOT YOU LIKE WHAT
HE'S SAYING OR IF THIS IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO AND QUITE
FRANKLY I DON'T CARE WHAT HE
WRITES IN AN OP-ED.
I CARE WHAT HE DOES IN THE
SENATE.
FOR REPUBLICANS, YOU ALL WILL
CARE A FEW VOTES WITH TRUMPCARE
FOR DEMOCRATS, WE WILL CARE IF
HE STANDS UP TO TRUMP LIKE JEFF
FLAKE ATTEMPTED, BOB CORKER A
TIME STATE.
REPUBLICANS, YOU SHOULD TAKE
THESE VOICES SERIOUSLY.
THEY HAVE GENUINE ARGUMENTS WITH
THE PRESIDENT'S BEHAVIOR.
THEY ARE NOT RIDICULOUS.
>> Greg: OKAY, KENNEDY, THE
BEHAVIOR HE'S REFERRING TO IS
NOW GOING ON HIS THIRD YEAR.
WE HAVE ALL COME TO GRIPS WITH
IT.
WE LOOK AT THE DEEDS IN OTHER
WORDS.
ROMNEY WAS SAYING THAT HE HAD A
BAD MONTH.
TO A LOT OF PEOPLE, IT WAS A
GOOD MONTH BECAUSE HE IS PULLING
2,000 TROOPS OUT OF SYRIA.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE
THAT'S GOOD.
>> Kennedy: AND THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE THAT WILL
SHOW THAT WE SHOULDN'T BE IN THE
MIDDLE EAST IN THE FIRST PLACE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT MITT ROMNEY
BECAUSE THAT'S ALL MITT ROMNEY
WANTS TO DO RIGHT NOW.
TO ANY INCOMING FRESHMAN
SENATOR, I PUT UP AND SHUT UP.
WE DON'T REALLY WANT TO HEAR
ABOUT YOUR FEELINGS AND HOW YOU
HAVE THE VAPORS AND YOU ARE
OFFENDED BY SOMEONE'S NARCISSISM
WHOSE BEHAVIOR REALLY HASN'T
CHANGED.
THE INTERESTING THING ABOUT
MITT ROMNEY IS YOU COULD ARGUE
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS A RESULT
OF MITT ROMNEY'S FAILURE BECAUSE
POLITICS, ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO THE PRESIDENCY, TENDS
TO BE A REACTION.
THE PENDULUM SWINGS.
YOU HAVE VERY --
ESPECIALLY AFTER TWO-TERM
PRESIDENT, ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS
LOOK AT CLINTON, BUSH.
THIS IS JUST IN THE MODERN ERA
AND THEN TO OBAMA.
OBAMA WAS THE OPPOSITE OF
GEORGE W. BUSH FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
EVEN INDEPENDENTS AND SOME OF
THE BALKANS.
NOW DONALD TRUMP IS THE EXACT
OPPOSITE OF PRESIDENT OBAMA.
IF MITT ROMNEY HAD WANTED 2012,
THERE WOULDN'T BE A
PRESIDENT TRUMP RIGHT NOW.
THAT'S WHEN HE ASKED
INTERNALIZE.
IF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THEM
AND THIS IS WHERE I HAVE A
LITTLE BIT MORE RESPECT FOR
PEOPLE LIKE LINDSEY GRAHAM AND
RAND PAUL, GO WITH SPECIFICS.
IF YOU HAVE A POLICY ISSUE, TALK
ABOUT IT AND DISSECT IT.
THAT'S WHERE YOU CAN HAVE --
>> Jesse: GRAHAM AND TRUMP
NEVER GOT ALONG.
THEY HATED EACH OTHER THE
PRIMARY.
TRUMP GIVE HIS CELL PHONE NUMBER
OUT.
NOW GRANDMA'S DINING WITH THE
PRESIDENT ALMOST EVERY DAY.
-- GRAHAM IS DINING WITH THE
IF YOU TRY TO WARM UP TO HIM AND
TRY TO MOVE HIM IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION ON POLICY.
>> Marie: IT DOESN'T WORK.
GRAHAM HAS HAD NO IMPACT ON
DONALD TRUMP'S FOREIGN POLICIES
AT ALL.
SPEED SIX I DISAGREE.
LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED WITH
SYRIA.
NOW HE'S EASING THE WITHDRAWAL.
HE'S COMMITTED A LOT LESS TROOPS
NOW AFTER HE SPOKE TO HIM.
>> Marie: IF THERE ISN'T ROOM
FOR A MITT ROMNEY AND
DONALD TRUMP'S PARTY, IT'S A
PROBLEM NATIONALLY.
>> Kennedy: THE PARTY HAS
PASSED HIM.
THE PARTY HAS PASSED
ESTABLISHMENT REPUBLICANS.
IT'S A CONSTANT EVOLUTION.
THE NANCY PELOSIS OF THE WORLD
STANDING STARK CONTRAST OF THE
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZS.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THE NEW
GENERATION IS BETTER THAN THE
ONE THEY ARE PASSING BUT THAT'S
HOW THE SYSTEM WORKS.
>> Greg: THE ONE THING THAT I
WANTED TO TALK ABOUT, TRUMP HAS
AN EFFECT ON EVERYBODY'S FAMILY.
IT DISRUPTS FAMILIES.
EVEN WITH MITT'S FAMILY, WITH